Donald Trump's cabinet selections
continue to suggest that the US will
continue going in the direction of the
dark ages after president-elect Donald
Trump takes office we now are talking
about orthopedic surgeon and Republican
representative Tom Price a six-time
congressman six-term congressman he is
president-elect Donald's choice to be
Secretary of Health and Human Services
Tom Price is one of the biggest destroy
Obamacare advocates uh I don't know how
that's going to play now that Trump is
called some of the Obamacare provisions
very good but there's one area where I
do want to give Tom Price credit most
Republicans who say repeal the
Affordable Care Act have no plan in
terms of what to replace it with Tom
Price has at least put forward something
called the empowering patient first act
now it's a total abortion it's a
disaster but at least it's something
right and it would include age-adjusted
tax credits for people to buy individual
and family health plans very very
supposedly pro-market plan uh it would
also have some incentives for people to
contribute to health savings accounts
and a few other provisions so what do we
know about Tom Price the guy who is
going to be the Secretary of Health and
Human Services let's go through some of
the ideas that we know about Tom Price
number one Tom Price supported
legislation to bar federal funds for
Planned Parenthood disaster number two
tom price as a score of zero from
Planned Parenthood Federation of America
that's a very low scores as you can
imagine zero is quite low on the number
line Tom Price referred to the quote
barbaric abortion practices at some
Planned Parenthood hood clinics and Tom
Price is an outspoken opponent of
abortion receiving a one hundred percent
rating from the national right to life
committee that's like getting an a-plus
from the NRA it's not good also called
the Supreme Court same-sex marriage
decision quote not only a sad day for
marriage but a further judicial
destruction of our entire system of
checks and balances that one makes me
throw up a little bit in my mouth also
Tom Price favorite amending the
Constitution to define traditional
marriage but can you think of something
more retrograde favors privatizing
Social Security a total and utter
disaster
and believes that marijuana is a gateway
drug rated a minus 10 by normal n 0 r ml
the end the drug war organization so
you're gonna have a guy running Health
and Human Services who thinks that a
crucial and legal medical procedure
should be abolished already a bad start
and then of course believes that it's a
great idea for healthcare to be at the
base level something for big
corporations to make money on hard to
think of a worse pic to be working in
the area of health and human services
isn't he yes but he can't act
unilaterally outside of Congress but I
mean from day one he will be able to
work from the branch of CMS that works
with that delivering testing
implementing payment for health care so
yeah I pretty broad this is an argument
that's be after every single one of
these horrible pics you have the people
who say absolute disaster this is that
this is a train wreck and then others
who say you know these federal positions
they sort of set the general direction
but they're not necessarily doing that
much I'm sort of in between i mean the
the federal outlook on a lot of these
issues does two things number one it
does influence states particularly
states that are of the same party so
when you have Republicans in the cabinet
their ideas are going to influence
republican legislatures across the
country and number two pat when it comes
to funding a lot of the things that
states do in these areas are funded
federally at least partially so it does
have an impact and he's talked even
about phasing out Medicare Medicaid and
in putting that responsibility more on
the states and I guess it is good that
he has a plan to replace Obamacare but
not if it's a bad one it's a bad plan
yet and you know up at we talked
yesterday Rachel about how the phrase in
looking for the silver lining dot dot
dot is going to be a very common phrase
during the the Trump administration yes
Tom Price is not so irresponsible that
he says get rid of Obamacare without
some kind of plan it happens to be a
horrible plan Bob but it's a plan
nonetheless and I I tend to be more on
the side of even if the specific powers
of some of these position
don't directly impact what goes on at
the state in many states maybe not
Massachusetts we've had Romneycare for
for much longer than the Affordable Care
Act has been around it is going to have
an impact I don't think we should
understate the importance of having a
nut like Tom Price in power I don't
think we should understate the
importance but I do think the silver
lining is what I said is that he can't
act unilaterally yeah okay well hey you
know you're you're jumping on board the
lettuce I'm let's find a silver lining a
meme that we're increasingly looking for
here